which I might kill you you were [ __ ]
me I just showed Sally a bunch of rats
ah I don't know why I just had this
imposition to show her some really dark
crap I thought we'd go off of the angry
wrap with reading mean comments by jenna
Marbles so I wanted to you know kind of
check this out because she's jenna
Marbles I imagine for someone her status
she had to learn to deal with hate and
you know like the bigger this channel
yes but your channel gets you get more
haters with that it's cut I want to see
how someone kind of finds their own way
to deal with it you know that's why I
want to check this out
she is so hot
okay so I asked you yesterday I wanna
Facebook what you guys wanted to see and
overwhelmingly you guys want me to rape
me in comments carpooling drunk I'm not
going to get drunk for this video but it
had the most likes more than any request
in recent memory so I really wanted to
make video that you guys won this week
because of sex we get it [ __ ] that
means this week we feel great so yeah
I've been putting off making this video
because it's a downer it's [ __ ] sad
so it's not an original idea it is not
my idea of many people have done this
Jimmy Kimmel does this so I've sort of
been posited to do it but
really wanted to see it so I wanted to
make you guys laugh this week by
trashing Jenna not all of them are
tweets I pulled comments from everywhere
like [ __ ] deep corners of the
internet forums I pulled them from all
over the place
here's the video that you want to see
this week I'm gonna read some mean
comments there's a lot o [ __ ] without
makeup on she looks like a guy watching
face 100 this jig is busted with that
ugly [ __ ] you are thanks Jesus she looks
so different without makeup that's a
shame she is one of those fake [ __ ]
oh my god she looks horrible [ __ ]
[ __ ] ellipses you're one of the most
famous people on YouTube it's kind of
like being the smartest person with
jenna Marbles is horrible and a thinker
she reminds me of the Katy Perry type
I'm one of the boys but girls can be
fierce gay everyone relate to me and the
cute things I do sighs die it throws
feminism backwards and I genuinely want
to throw up in one of her videos sigh
sorry that I just wanted to get it off
my chest
the facts of movies on a Facebook page
called jenna Marbles and her fans are
mentally [ __ ] she doesn't know her
skin color I guess and she hangs out
with tools that just want to get laid my
god you're marvelous might associate
leave idiot
pretty much every jennamarbles said what
winners a real woman a fake [ __ ] says
the one on the right is more idolized
[ __ ] humanity jenna marbles are not a
stripper
same [ __ ] correction used to be buzz
larger mama's new funny video where my
friend says when you cuffs you shorten
your days
looks like jenna is gonna die very soon
suck [ __ ] ASAP what's the nail market
what what what's the nail mark on your
nose bridge lol it's a scar you always
post selfies and your hair always looks
like [ __ ] people who actually support
jenna Marbles should just be shot on
sight
seriously they're too stupid to keep
alive
jenna Marbles is for sheep she got one
on the end face nice body
put that face really ugly yeah she's
[ __ ] difficult I'm not sure she knows
or not Oh a slightly [ __ ]
majority of her videos how anyone can
watch this chick is beyond me I think
it's a ripoff Oh Jake Jenna Maroney as I
didn't mean I just to quote it [ __ ]
you're elevate you not to mention a dumb
Kazakh [ __ ] but I bet you get that all
the time I just hope you die so you're
saying no makeup so you're saying no
makeup no sucky cocky and with lipstick
swallows bit or gargles one of them you
just hope you died you are [ __ ] ugly
holy [ __ ]
so faith this is not really Cyprus
you're a bad man okay Jenna was funny at
this time space exhibition point now she
is just stupid and never funny
you are fingerprinted shut up and go die
[ __ ] always has chipped nail polish
[ __ ] gutter flute know girls who
parades a stupid toy size dog like that
will ever have respect sorry
the writers suck my writers do some
Jenna your fire Danny I knew this was
coming suck all right you done white
girl you may not want [ __ ]
grinding up on you in the club now
within ten years when you're
30-something and you're crying to your
friends saying why doesn't it
want me I'm going to be alone forever
think back to this moment when you
posted this dumbass video hmm she is
sexy but then again I about gay I hate
that stupid unfunny kuch Slynt
I would [ __ ] her but only if I can
brutally murder her afterwards she looks
like she was born in a wind tunnel I
would destroy her badge and dump her in
the lake back there dead [ __ ] is
[ __ ] hideous even with me go her bids
are pretty dumb and she's almost 30
square Jenny Stowe and snoop doge she
looks like a 40 year old going to a
Kesha concert there's the time at a
place for purple blue green pink hair
and it's not past the age of 24 unless
you're a pop artist slash musician grow
up Christ
kind of embarrassing really better click
to the YouTube thing because people
don't taking very seriously when you act
like you're 17
oh gee by the way am I alone in thinking
that her eyeliner is terrible and gross
nope it looks like a freaking sharpie on
a side note it substrata marbles wasn't
around when my mom used to frown at me
and tell me my room was messy it was
never even a third of the mess in her
house she's pretty near to the 10 out of
10 body in my book tight-ass big teddies
next shaped good legs too bad a buck a
face but you can't have it all that's
why God invented paper bags am I the
only one who thinks she's [ __ ]
awkward and slow looking she said what
if I lift
competitions and I can convert that she
is awkward in real life and it dem
titties you look like the road so yeah I
hope that this video made you laugh
because it's what you guys wanted to see
this week as we're crazy [ __ ] you look
like you were born in a wind tunnel
ok make sure you subscribe to my channel
and put it would be except your wings it
except sometimes are on Thursday and by
sometimes I mean like every [ __ ] week
so just like hear the word Wednesday and
just let it turn into Thursday in your
mind we're on the same page Malloy I'm
gonna go up myself
great that's one big transit right
school brother help me you know I really
enjoyed that video I did too but I felt
kind of sad cuz sometimes like when she
would laugh I could tell she was
actually really sad about what they said
it was in her eyes really because I had
to me it seemed like she was a little
bit of me into it well I've seen other
videos of other youtubers that
completely laugh at it but in her is it
seem like oh kind of sad laugh her big
laughs were genuine but her face didn't
I just love watching her and embrace
this whole situation and rather than
like letting it defeat her she's
benefiting from it by turning it into a
funny video I don't know if I'd ever do
that I think I would like that sounds
like a great thing cuz I could see how
it could be like an outlet yeah I mean
it would be fun to make fun of myself I
wouldn't want to give the haters like
recognition for it uh yeah but then I
think you might get more because I
noticed even I'm like the real rejects
when there's fans that really stick by
you like someone could hate on this
channel because there's a lot of haters
that come along but then the [ __ ]
fans are awesome and they're like
they will back you [ __ ] it up it's just
like the main one I get are just really
gross and I'm just like I you should be
in jail for that comment it's like yes
in those comments were awful but it's
better than letting it just defeat you
that was actually really worth it's kind
of inspiring to actually watch it is
funny because it is something where I'm
watching it I am getting that feeling
like I'm hanging out with Jenna right
now you know like you feel like you're a
friend of hers I don't get that feeling
often with YouTube so yeah that's really
good she's so popular because you have
to be really personable with them yeah
like you are cuz we care about you guys
yeah it's all about fans it's all about
the fans somewhere to come up to me like
hey Ryan what's this channel about I'd
say the fans hey gosh is it game on here
you know cool me down the fans so if
you're new to the channel that you kids
it's gonna be the real react man how
cool is all cuz it is really yeah and if
you're a fan of Sally you could
subscribe to her channel you can follow
us on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
she has a snapchat now I don't have it
and thank you Jenna Marbles for being as
hot and sexy as you are I like you with
or without makeup you are just so yeah
Jenna you don't look like you're down
syndrom no you don't look at you
everyone looks like they have down
syndrome sometimes but you know like I
don't know some people that was a
metaphor for some people have moments we
really feel ugly but you're not so never
let it get to you
I will cover any topic or comedy you
name it abortion rape no AIDS but never
would I cover Down syndrome you never
would I covered